FORWARD.
>>> TODAY HOUSE SPEAKER NANCY
PELOSI ANNOUNCED HER EIGHT PICKS
FOR THE COMMITTEE TO INVESTIGATE
THE JANUARY 6TH INSURRECTION.
THE MOST NOTABLE NAME WAS NOT IN
THE ROOM.
PELOSI APPOINTED LIZ CHENEY AS
ONE OF THE EIGHT SLOTS.
LIZ CHENEY STRIPPED OF HER
REPUBLICAN POSITION AFTER VOTING
TO IMPEACH TRUMP.
KEVIN McCARTHY THREATENED TO
PULL ANY COMMITTEE FROM ANY
REPUBLICAN WHO ACCEPTED PELOSI'S
OFFER TO SERVE ON THE PANEL.
I WANT TO BRING IN CHIP ROY OF
TEXAS.
THANKS FOR JOINING US AND THANKS
FOR BEING PATIENT.
REPUBLICAN LEADER McCARTHY
CALLING IT UNPRECEDENTED THAT
YOUR COLLEAGUE LIZ CHENEY WOULD
ACCEPT THE OFFER BY SPEAKER
PELOSI.
TAKE A LISTEN.
>> I DON'T KNOW IN HISTORY WHERE
SOMEONE WOULD GO GET THEIR
COMMITTEE ASSIGNMENTS FROM THE
SPEAKER AND EXPECT TO BE IN THE
CONFERENCE AS WELL.
I WAS SHOCKED SHE WOULD ACCEPT
SOMETHING FROM SPEAKER PELOSI.
IT SEEMED TO ME, AS I DIDN'T
HEAR FROM HER, MAYBE SHE'S
CLOSER TO HER THAN US.
I DON'T KNOW.
>> CONGRESSMAN ROY, YOU'VE
SPOKEN IN SUPPORT OF LIZ CHENEY
IN THE PAST.
WHAT'S YOUR REACTION TO THAT?
>> FIRST OF ALL, LET ME JUST SAY
OUR PRAYERS ARE WITH THE FOLKS
IN FLORIDA.
IT'S A TERRIBLE TRAGEDY.
I HAVE NO PROBLEM WAITING FOR
THE PRESIDENT TO ADDRESS THAT.
GOOD TO BE WITH YOU, JAKE.
I DON'T THINK THERE SHOULD BE
ANY REAL SURPRISE HERE.
I THINK THERE'S A DIFFERENCE OF
OPINION ON THIS MATTER WITH MY
FRIEND LIZ CHENEY AND WHERE A
LOT OF THE CONFERENCES.
THAT IS AT THE HEART OF THE
MATTER AND WHY SHE IS NO LONG
TER COLONGER
THE CONFERENCE CHAIR.
I SAY, I'M ON THE JUDICIARY
COMMITTEE.
WE HAVE OVERSIGHT OVER THE
DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE WHICH IS
EXECUTING INVESTIGATIONS.
IT HAS ARRESTED OVER 500
AMERICANS.
I THINK WE NEED TO HAVE
OVERSIGHT AND HAVE A REPORT OUT
OF THE DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE.
WE HAD TWO REPORTS ISSUED OUT OF
THE SENATE FROM TWO COMMITTEES
THERE.
THEY WENT THROUGH A LOT OF
SECURITY BREAKDOWNS.
WE HAD THE HOUSE COMMITTEE ON
ADMINISTRATION WHERE WE CAN GO
THROUGH AND SEE WHAT HAPPENED
WITH THE SECURITY BREAKDOWNS AND
WHAT HAPPENED WITH THE CAPITOL
POLICE.
MY POINT BEING OVERSIGHT HAS
BROAD POWERS, WHICH I USED TO
SEARCH ON THE OVERSIGHT
COMMITTEE.
WE HAVE ALL THE AUTHORITY WE
NEED ON THE COMMITTEES WE NEED.
I DON'T KNOW WHY WE'RE NOT GOING
THROUGH AND GETTING REPORTS THAT
WAY.
THAT'S WHAT THE SENATE DID.
I THINK THAT'S WHAT THE HOUSE
OUGHT TO DO.
I THINK MY COLLEAGUES VIEW THIS
AS POLITICAL THEATER BY THE
SPEAKER.
THAT'S THE FRUSTRATION THAT IS
KIND OF PLAYING INTO THE
NARRATIVE THERE AND PLAYING INTO
THEIR HANDS BY MAKING IT MORE
ABOUT POLITICAL THEATER THAN
FOLLOWING THE TRUTH.
I'D LIKE TO KNOW ABOUT THE
INVESTIGATIONS OF 500 ARRESTED
AMERICANS.
WHY, WHO ARE THEY, WHAT DID THEY
DO?
>> YOU HAVE BEEN WILLING TO
CRITICIZE FORMER PRESIDENT
TRUMP'S BEHAVIOR AFTER THE
ELECTION FOR PUSHING THE
ELECTION LIES AND MORE.
TRUMP HAS ATTACKED YOU FOR IT.
WHEN YOU RAN FOR A HOUSE
LEADERSHIP QUESTION TRUMP SAID,
I CAN'T IMAGINE REPUBLICANS
WOULD GO WITH CHIP ROY.
THE ONLY REASON UP BRING IT UP
IS BECAUSE YOU WERE WITH TRUMP
YESTERDAY WHEN HE VISITED THE
BORDER THERE IN TEXAS.
DID YOU HAVE ANY RESERVATIONS
ABOUT JOINING HIM ON THE BORDER?
>> I DON'T HAVE ANY RESERVATIONS
WHATSOEVER.
I'M A CONGRESSMAN FROM THE TGRET
STATE OF TEXAS.
THE DISTRICT I REPRESENT IS
ABOUT 100 MILES FROM THE BORDER,
THE OPEN BORDER CRISIS WE'RE
HAVING IS HAVING A DIRECT IMPACT
ON THE PEOPLE I REPRESENT.
ANYBODY WHO FOLLOWS POLITICS,
LITERALLY ANYONE, KNOWS EXACTLY
WHERE I COME FROM IDENTITY
LOGILO
LOGICALLY.
I HAVE A STRONG RECORD SUP
SUPPORTING AMERICA FIRST.
I DON'T DANCE FOR ANYONE.
I DON'T DANCE FOR THE LEA
P
LEADERSHIP.
I REPRESENT THE 750,000 TEXANS
WHO I'M SUPPOSED TO REPRESENT.
WHEN I FIGHT FOR THE THINGS I
BELIEVE IN, I WILL DO THAT.
I KNOW THE PRESIDENT KNOWS THAT.
SO I HAVE NO QUALMS GOING TO THE
BORDER, STANDING THERE IN FRONT
OF THE FENCE THAT IS NOT
FINISHED, STANDING NEXT TO
700,000 APPREHENSIONS THAT HAVE
OCCURRED ALONG OUR SOUTHERN
BORDER.
IT'S PART OF THE BORDER THAT
VICE PRESIDENT KAMALA HARRIS HAS
NOT GONE TO.
SHE PIT STOPPED IN EL PASO,
WHICH IS 750 MILES AWAY FROM
McALLEN WHERE THE CRISIS
ACTUALLY IS.
>> LET ME ASK YOU ABOUT THE
BORDER CRISIS.
DEMOCRATIC CONGRESSMAN CUELLAR
OF TEXAS WAS ON THE SHOW
YESTERDAY.
HE SPOKE ABOUT THE HUMANITARIAN
CRISIS AT THE BORDER.
WHAT MORE DO YOU THINK NEEDS TO
BE DONE TO STOP THE MIGRANTS
FROM MAKING THIS DANGEROUS
JOURNEY CREATING THE CRISIS
YOU'RE TALKING ABOUT?
>> I THINK THIS IS PRETTY
SIMPLE.
WE DO NEED TO MAINTAIN TITLE 42.
TITLE 42 IS THE HEALTH CODE THAT
ALLOWS US TO TURN PEOPLE BACK
BECAUSE OF THE PANDEMIC.
THE VAST MAJORITY OF THE PEOPLE
COMING ACROSS THE RIVER, COMING
HERE FOR ECONOMIC REASONS.
GOD BLESS THEM.
I UNDERSTAND IT.
WHEN I GO TO THE RIVER, JAKE --
LAST NIGHT I WENT DOWN TO THE
RIVER.
I WAS DOWN THERE AND THERE WERE
700 MIGRANTS IN A HOLDING
FACILITY THAT HAD COME IN THE
TWO OR THREE HOURS BEFORE ON THE
LATE AFTERNOON SHIFT.
THIS IS A REAL PROBLEM THAT
EVERYONE I TALK TO -- AND I
TALKED TO SOME YESTERDAY IN MY
BROKEN SPANISH.
I SAID WHY DID YOU COME?
THEY SAY FOR JOBS, ECONOMIC
OPPORTUNITY, ET CETERA.
I UNDERSTAND THAT.
BUT THAT'S NOT ASYLUM.
ASYLUM IS A VERY SPECIFIC LAW ON
OUR BOOKS HELPING PEOPLE FLEEING
FROM PERSECUTION.
WE CAN'T PUT ASYLUM POSTERS ON
TREES NEXT TO THE RIO GRANDE AND
ENCOURAGING THE ENTIRE WORLD TO
FLOOD OUR BORDERS.
WE NEED TO HAVE AN IMMIGRATION
SYSTEM THAT SENDS A SIGNAL THAT
HERE'S HOW YOU COME, YOU GET IN
LINE, HERE'S HOW THE NUMBERS
WORK AND IF YOU TRULY NEED
ASYLUM FROM PERSECUTION, HERE'S
HOW YOU DO IT.
WE CAN FIX IT IN A MINUTE.
HECK, OBAMA'S POLICIES FIVE
YEARS AGO WHEN BIDEN WAS VICE
PRESIDENT WERE VERY STRONG
COMPARED TO WHAT WE'RE DOING
TODAY COMPARED TO WIDE OPEN
BORDERS.
>> CHIP RO